la ciudad de que nos ha en wisconsin
ardió una noche más por el tiroteo de un
policía a jake blake un
afroestadounidense que no portaba un
arma el nivel de destrucción en la
ciudad fue muy alto algo que obligó el
gobernador a instaurar el toque de queda
y a pedir ayuda a la guardia nacional a
pesar de condenar el presunto abuso
policial cometido el pasado domingo
contra blake debemos comenzar el largo
pero importante camino para asegurar que
nuestro estado y nuestro país comiencen
a cumplir nuestras promesas de equidad y
justicia las imágenes aéreas de que no
se muestran la gravedad de los
incidentes un ejemplo más del cansancio
de la población por lo que consideran
ataques racistas y uso excesivo de la
fuerza la policía propinó siete disparos
en la espalda a blake después de recibir
un aviso de incidente doméstico y de que
el ciudadano no les hiciera caso cuando
le detuvieron su abogado confirmó que
los disparos causaron parálisis en blake
confirmado jake blake está actualmente
paralizado en la cintura para abajo
recemos para que no sea permanente
las protestas raciales sacuden eeuu
desde la muerte de georg floyd en mayo
al punto que el tema de la brutalidad
policial y el racismo institucional ha
entrado de lleno en la campaña
presidencial de 2020